anh Alo ạ
khoa học bạ
ở Hà Nội
ở huyện đặt Linh Tý
Ừ như hôm trước hả Thêm gầy á ride Ít
sai vậy
Việt kiều mất bài 18 rồi
ừ ừ
à à
à à à à
hôm nay
hôm nay mình vẫn muốn tranh thủ nói tâm
sự một tí
em về à hai cái cái đầu tiên thì mình
thấy là không biết mình đừng nói các bạn
chưa đó là mình làm con người khá là là
để để xem là là kiểu người khác có tiện
Điều đấy không tiền thì nhất là những
cái nhỏ như ví dụ như là nhắn tin sao
cho người ta sẽ sao chép là cái cái mình
rất thích nhắn tin sao cho thứ nhất là
mình đã từng nói các bạn vừa nhắn tin ở
trên đúng nền ra để hiểu dặm cầu dạng là
nó cho nó chui nghiệp ví dụ Giả sử nhé
động ví dụ Giả sử đơn giản thôi đó là
khi mấy ông nhắn con mèo này khi gửi
mail cái gì đó thì nó nên là lịch sự chị
chặn không ạ Nó không được cơ thì lúc
đấy không có biểu tượng đủ cơm chứ không
lấy cả đấy tiếp theo là nếu mà nhắn tin
qua Messenger thì nó sẽ mang đến sức
thoải mái hơn vì nó không phải kênh công
việc là xử thế
ạ
và ở telegram thị hay discord gì đó nếu
mà là kênh công việc các bạn thì nó lại
phải chị chọn hai gì đó đón Vân và khi
nhắn sao cho mà để cho người dùng Nếu
giả sử người dùng điện thoại lạ càng dễ
thể sao chép mình rồi đấy có thấy thực
đại khái ít người làm với vụ này ngay từ
việc là mấy ông gửi số tài khoản để
chuyển khoản Hay là số điện thoại để mà
copy để mà tùy dừng Cái máy điện thoại
thì không thể nhận diện được số điện
thoại để một copy nhưng mà có nhiều cái
thì nó là chữ hai cái gì đấy khó khó mà
copy em ạ hoặc gà ngắn đoạn Mã để mà
teamview hay ở ultraview gì đó mấy ông
cũng kiểu chụp màn hình gửi người ta cần
tôi hãy thử các bạn mình không về chưa
Để ý kỹ mấy cái chi tiết nhỏ đấy nó nó
hơi bị khó chịu rồi Dùng từ hơi bị khó
chịu hoặc là khi mà gửi cho người ta cái
số tài khoản thì đương nhiên là người
ông sẽ gửi thêm cả tên của Ngân hàng
không ạ Nhưng nếu gửi trong chung trong
một cái tin nhắn nữa rất khó copy không
ạ tạm biệt khi dùng điện thoại nó sẽ rất
khó copy
em ăn iPhone thì có thể nhận diện được
cái số thỉnh thoảng thỉnh thoảng thế
nhưng mà thẳng Android đôi khi nó không
nhận được diện được số người ta sẽ làm
nhà người ta phải nhớ là có bị lại ai
đâu phải gõ lại ạ
cho nên tính tôi trước này thì những cái
gì mà biết được người ta sẽ dùng để copy
thì
tôi sẽ gửi cho người ta tin nhắn nhiều
tách riêng nó không tốn cái gì cả nó
không phải là tin nhắn nhiều điện thoại
bình thường mà Mà đấy Đúng rồi copy hết
Xong rồi lại phải biết chỗ khác thì xóa
đúng không Nếu không thấy tự nhiên lại
làm người ta phức tạp thêm một bước nữa
không đúng ạ tôi Tại sao không phải nhắn
hay giọng hay tin hay 3 tin gì đó nó có
tốn tiền gì đâu đúng không ạ
Anh không hiểu em nhắn hay sao cháu tiện
rồi cảm thấy à thế cái đấy nó chẳng khác
hay Ở đấy một cái tôi thấy rất tinh ý
Thật ý à
Ừ Nhiều lúc tôi nhắn cho người khác
địa chỉ tôi thường nhắn địa chỉ để cho
dễ copy cũng như là thậm chí tôi ném cả
Google Map lên Google Map luôn để nó ra
dễ theo dõi
dễ hiểu biết luôn vị trí kiểu nhiều
người hôm qua địa hình hôm qua chẳng hạn
ạ Bạn ấy nhắn nữa tôi cái địa chỉ mà
trên Google Maps mà nó nói nhảy đi đâu
đấy Xong rồi à Bà Ơi Bà là ví dụ ví dụ
nha hôm qua rồi đến địa chỉ đủ 100 được
ạ xong rồi gồm anh chỉ đi đâu Ấy xong
này hiểu lại bảo là thực ra tao ở 100b
chứ không phải 100 đấy xong ngồi kiểu
100b nó lại đi Nhảy đi xa hơn nữa Chả
thế ngồi đúng kiểu cũ nhưng sự thật là
không nên để con gái chỉ đường này không
ạ làng sợ kinh khủng
xong rồi tôi bảo là gửi
gửi link Google Maps nó có biết rồi
chẳng hạn thế gửi vị trí không để gửi
Ừ thế này là tốt nhất ở Tôi nghĩ à
không ạ Có nghĩa là cái này là sợ ra mấy
ông đôi khi không để ý gì đâu tôi chỉ
nhắc khéo thế cho kìa vì ông hiểu tự
nhiên mình thành mỗi người tinh tế hơn
khi mà nhắn cái gì đó Khi ngắn có thể là
mình vẫn lịch sự mình nên lịch sự là
không miss nói thật là mét chia sẻ vị
trí chán cực telegram chia sẻ vị trí gọi
đỉnh uống thử mà em mắt nó xài nó vẫn
ngon tỉ đúng có sai
kể cả Google Maps nó cũng có sai nhưng
mà tr chưa thể vị trí gia đình mấy ông
thử khi nào lạc nhau tìm nhau mừng Tara
thì ông sẽ thấy cái chia sẻ vị trí của
nó gần như chính xác như nào so với
thằng Mat size hiểu
Google Maps à
nói chung mà cái này là tôi khuyên này
mấy ông tinh tế hơn trong những cái
những cái đấy thôi Mình là dân công nghệ
nữa mình nên kiểu mình cũng cậu nên áp
dụng công nghệ các kiểu thứ để cho nó
tinh Nó kiểu nó sĩ hơn trong mình có vẻ
là Ừ Khi mà nhắn tin ở mình nó toát ra
mình ở Dân công nghệ kiểu gì thế thật
đấy bởi vì ví dụ giống như là mấy lần
tôi đi đâu đấy tôi toàn chia sẻ vị trí
tôi Google Map rồi Kiểu à Tao đang qua
chỗ mày rồi này Đấy Hòa Tao đang trên
đường về tôi chia sẻ vị trí của tôi đi
đến cái điện đấy Kéo theo thời gian thu
của chân sau gửi cái link đề qua Linh
Google Map đấy Cho cho bạn kia chẳng hạn
thì thì người ta sẽ dễ theo dõi con thứ
là biết được mình đang đi đâu rồi qua
Vân và còn bao lâu nữa có thể đến dự
định và bao lâu đến nữa đến
xe tải thì người ta sẽ chuẩn bị hơn cho
Tân cái nhỏ nhỏ từng cái nhỏ một Nếu
không thể hiện sự tinh tế các thứ thử
thì tôi nghĩ về cơ bản thì ông cảm thấy
ông
em tự Ông cảm thấy mình chuyên nghiệp
hay trưởng thành dần hơn có nghĩa thế
ờ
ờ tiếp theo thì thực ra thì
cũng trước mình có nói đó là
ờ
ờ chuyện mà ở trên công ty của mình có
một chị chị bị tai nạn ở hôm đấy được ra
khá tiêu cực rồi Khá nặng rồi Nhưng mình
cố tránh nói đưa xấu nhưng có vẻ là hôm
qua thì bị thông báo là chị mất rồi thì
ra là thì tôi mới gặp chị có đúng một
lần thôi Nhưng mà chị ở trong miền Nam
mà nên là gần đây thì có
kiểu công ty tổ chức du lịch chị có ra
đây không gặp đúng một lần tin một lần
này Nhưng mà mình khá thiện cảm với chị
đấy vì ở một phần chị xinh à
cá thử nha Cái vấn đề ở đây Ý tao không
muốn nói
nói là kiểu gần như là khi mình kiểu
thấy mọi thứ đang rất là gấu bình thường
ấy mọi thứ ra bình thường Đột nhiên có
một cái tên gì rõ ra bất ngờ cứ như thế
Mình cảm thấy là cẩu
U70 bạn đúng nghĩa là cuộc sống theo cậu
là không ai lường trước được một cái gì
cả mọi thứ nó thể diễn ra bất ngờ
la la la bên ngồi gần thế
à mà không có nút reset thì ở đây cả Chả
có cái gì làm lại hai cái gì đây cả
Không ạ
có chuyện đấy thì đến với tất cả mọi
người đúng ạ Thế nên là tôi cảm thấy à à
à mà ra hồi trước hồi trước của tôi từ
nghĩ về cái việc là
Ừ nếu là sử mình mất đi sẽ thế nào
nói mấy cái này công nhận tiêu cực thật
nhưng mà ý tôi là hồi trước cả
và đặc biệt là hồi mà được vào công ty
đa cấp thường hay động chạm với mấy cái
liên quan mấy cái ô tô này để mà kiểu
lại lấy cảm xúc của mình nhiều ý mình mà
càng nhiều cảm xúc thì nó sẽ càng dễ lừa
kiểu như thế thì nó còn nói việc là kiểu
tưởng tượng khi mình vì ra đi thì mọi
thứ sẽ xảy ra như nào mà vật thì Hồi đấy
tôi khá nghĩ nhiều về việc là là
áo kiểu à
mẹ nó nhỉ
thì mình nên để lại một cái gì đó mình
cậu dạng nhà
nhọn như là khiến cho người khác phải
nhớ thì nó người khác phải ít nhất là
đến đến lắm đã mình trả lại
Anh ấy cho tôi từng xem bộ phim mà cái
nhân vật chính quá tệ khiến cho không có
một người thân ở đến dự đám tang nghe
cái đấy lịch sự rất là buồn nếu hiểu rất
buồn rất nặng nề Nếu sửa mình Mình biết
được cái sự thật đấy không ạ Mình nhìn
được cái sự thật đấy nếu cứ thử tưởng
tượng Cửu dem kiểu
đi đám tang ông chả có ai Nuối Tiếc à
thằn thế chẳng ai ở đến
lúc đấy chứng tỏ ông sống rồi anh không
quá tệ đâu ạ 3 và tiếp theo là người ta
sẽ đến người ta sẽ nhớ về mình là con
người như thế nào hãy thấy người ta có
khóc không nghe khóc với tiền của ông
hay là như thế nào khóc đây còn nước mắt
giả tạo để lấy tiền của ông hay như thế
nào không ạ hai người đã thực sự là
chiều
a cho cảm thấy nó nhưng mà cái gì ở mất
mát để Vân
Ê nghĩ mày cả đấy khiến cho
Anh khiến cho kiểu dạng là
khi tôi cảm thấy là tôi phải sống sao
cho kiểu nó ổn hơn sống cố gắng hơn
đi đái Giả sử bây giờ giả sử Giả sử là
bây giờ có nhiều người biết đến tôi ở
chả nhãn về sau khi mà mình bị làm sau
đấy thì có người quan tâm cảm thấy thôi
tôi thì thôi là tôi nghĩ đơn giản thế
thôi
cà phê
tôi tôi nghĩa đấy
em chọn nó sẽ không bị nổi tiếc người
không Hiểu không mà sẽ không bị nuối
tiếc kéo khi mình khi mình mất mình nói
tiếp cái gì đó
Ê mấy ông biết cái cảm giác kiểu thứ
tưởng tượng đi cứ tưởng tượng việc à Ông
mất nhưng mà không trực tiếp nuôi rất
nhiều thứ rất nhiều thứ chưa làm được
thử thứ chơi để lại được một cái gì cả
thì chắc chắn là khi mà ông xấu cũng sẽ
nghĩ khác không ạ rồi chưa có rất nhiều
câu nói của đã đại khái như thế nó kiểu
chúng ta chỉ sống một lần thôi hoặc gà
hãy sống như hôm nay ngày cùng văn ngày
giờ vẫn vở thức ăn nó có thực sự cũng
đúng như thế nhà em chị ở ông phải
sống sao nó có ý nghĩa một tí văn
Ừ đúng ạ
Ừ tôi hiểu về cá nhân tôi thì ở tôi Tuy
ở trong nhà nhiều thực sự rất nhiều
nhưng mà tôi Tôi cảm thấy là tôi cũng
tranh thủ được hãy khá nhiều hơn nghĩa
tận hưởng khá nhiều
A
Gọi trải nghiệm khá nhiều sự thứ
vì tội mong là mấy ông kiểu cũng dần dần
sẽ như thế không phải là kiểu về sau
nhận ra được sau mình hai mấy tuổi thậm
chỉ ba mấy tuổi đầu rồi ra xử thế thôi
cũng chưa ca sự trải đời hay mọi thứ vẫn
rất lạ ít hạ thế chúng ta chỉ làm đi làm
lại những cái thứ mà chúng ta thường hay
làm xong rồi cầu bị an phận rồi trong
cái công việc hay Môi trường đấy
vì tôi nghĩa là nó không hề hay cả tôi
nghĩ thế
ở để sang xuyên này có bị thoáng
không ạ
khi các bạn đang theo từng buổi còn đang
bị xóa nên tôi nghĩ là không
không không nên nhảy người khóc hãy hiểu
à
tao học phần mềm mà cảm thấy sức khỏe
không cho phép ngồi 8 tiếng thì có nên
chưa có phần cứng người thân sắp chết
cho không ạ
Đúng là một sự thật là nếu mà theo ngành
này thì ông phải quen được với cái việc
ngồi nhiều nhưng là quen ở trong khoảng
thời gian thôi chứ thực tế không ai cũng
thể ngồi nhiều thế này được mãi đâu ạ
thì cho cái thì tuổi thọ cái này ở tuổi
đời của cái ngày này mắn ca nhạc tuổi
đời cùng thứ tuổi đời đúng không sao
tuổi nghề đi thì nó nhắn thế nên là mỗi
tôi dừng người thì người ta sẽ ngồi
hưởng đến ít nhất là 30 tuổi Giả sử thế
chú ý nhất thì không biết dùng từ đúng
hay không đôi khi là nhiều nhất cũng
ngồi ít nhất là cái đại khái Thế còn là
nói chung vào cái này ở là do xem là bạn
muốn theo ngành này không Nếu muốn và
thấy là thức ăn nó phù hợp nó chị bị
chửi ngại mỗi phần kia thì ông sẽ phải
tự Cải thiện sức khỏe của ông thôi chứ
không nên à đương nhiên là sức khỏe Nó
ảnh hưởng rất nhiều cầu rằng là tôi
không khuyên với ông là cơn kiểu phá sức
để mà làm theo một cái gì đó không nhưng
mà nhưng mà kiểu thực sự thì
Ừ nếu mà ông chỉ vì mỗi cái trở ngại duy
nhất đấy ông ạ để mà kiểu thay vì mình
Cải thiện sức khỏe mình lên thì mình lại
tìm công việc gì đó nhàn hạ hơn luôn cái
công việc nhàn hạ hơn nó sẽ luôn dẫn đến
mình ở kiểu dạng lương nó sẽ thấp hơn
mọi thử nó sẽ thay đổi nữa đúng ạ Ông ấy
phải học lại từ đầu có vân nên là ông cứ
cân nhắc thôi còn nhắc bài toán mà ông
thấy cái nào phù hợp hơn vô tội tội chỉ
nói ra đầu mối thế
chỉ sau khoảng 15 chuyên sâu vào học là
chính web em cảm thấy giống như mình học
hết được những cái thức ăn học vậy
anh giống như em giải quyết được hết các
thắc mắc lúc chưa học
ạ Và bây giờ là mất niềm vui và định
hướng khi học lập trình web ha
Ừ ông mà giải thích giải quyết được mọi
thắc mắc hay ở học hết được thì chứng tỏ
là ông hoặc sai rồi
đến vừa tôi cũng thấy là tôi cảm cảm
thấy tôi vẫn đang bé nhỏ kiểu gọi là
Suneo thì nhẹ ai bởi vì về các bạn thì
mình biết cách giải quyết vấn đề mình
cũng kiểu chẳng biết tôi yêu có thử thứ
và nhân nhưng mà ở
Ừ để tự ti Nó kiểu mình giỏi thì không
Tôi không tự tin mình giỏi gì cả thật ra
tôi cũng chưa gặp ai thực sự nó giỏi sự
rất giỏi trong cái ngày này rất giỏi nhé
được cậu là lập trình của em đấy còn
những ngành hát là nói cho tôi biết rồi
nhưng mà ở vì các bạn thì tôi gặp tôi
chưa gặp người giỏi trong cái lập trình
web nhưng tôi vẫn không khẳng định đưa
giỏi đấy nó con như thế còn bây giờ ông
bà là ông đã học hết thì cậu chưa biết
ông sẽ như nào ờ ờ
là có thể bạn ấy bảo là chỉ nó mang tính
chất ở cậu hiểu hết được những cái mà
mình từng Thắng Mắt Còn bây giờ thì có
kiến thức thì nó vẫn rộng mình thể học
thêm cái người thứ nhưng mà Đúng là nếu
mà hết cái thứ mà kiểu một thử thách
mình thì không có nghĩa là kiểu trong
mấy ngày này chiếu thử thách trong ngày
này thời gian nó rộng lắm ông mới chị
làm được việc thôi còn tối ưu
à Còn tối Hí nó mới là bài toán khó ở
đây nó có hai ngưỡng lúc đầu nó lúc đầu
các bạn có quá nhiều thứ để học
kiểu quá nhiều cái sách tài liệu các thử
để đọc để mà học xong cái hiểu Cái lõi
hiểu về cơ bản sau đó thì bây giờ sẽ đến
ngưỡng là gần như là sợi rất ít Kiên rất
kìa có nhiều kiến thức nhưng mà rất ít
tài liệu này mà đọc thực sự đến tầm Sino
cái này thì tài liệu đề mà đọc Chuyến
sau ấy giống như là để tôi dậy mấy cái
mà Mấy ông vì ông xem ấy ít người dậy
lắm ít người viết lắm nói thẳng như thế
người ra đôi khi người đã không muốn
chia sẻ và chia sẻ Thực ra cũng kém
người đọc thì người ta phải chia sẻ thì
cả cái chia sẻ Mình cần nâng cao mà ít
lắm cùng lắm chỉ chia sẻ mẹo vặt thỉnh
thoảng chia sẻ mẹo vặt và và gần như là
Ừ để tao vẫn đang hướng đến dạy cơ bản
nhiều hơn hiểu gì tôi không nếu uống thử
tìm trên mạng cho em tìm đặc biệt lại
như tôi đã từng Tìm tìm suốt mà xem
người ông có mấy ai dạy nâng cao các thứ
từ đâu ông ạ ra có sống dậy chuyên sau
hẳn một bài toán cụ thể cùng lắm là nó
chỉ có ngắm này hướng dẫn và cách viết
code như thế nào kiểu cho nó kiểu cho nó
đẹp
cho nó hướng đối tượng theo một mô hình
ở đó thôi đúng ạ Người ta có hướng dẫn
với ông giải quyết một vấn đề gì đó đâu
có lắm thì nó sẽ giật Tít ở kiểu Đây là
cách mà cậu Facebook hay ở mấy cái gì
người cái công nghệ lớn đang làm chỉ thế
thôi nhưng người ta không hướng đến cho
ông giải quyết một bài toán nghiệp vụ
thực sự đúng ạ em muốn tìm mấy ông mà
tìm được thì cũng gửi tôi với Tôi đọc
cho tôi khẳng định thì có khi ở bây giờ
chẳng ai hướng đến dạy kiểu như này cả
đúng ạ ạ
à à à Nên là bài toán bài toán nghĩa vụ
này toán về
tối ưu nó rất nhiều cái đau đầu
Ừ cái đấy Mày là tải mà thực sự nó mới
thử thách con cái mà để mà ông hiểu rõ
bản chất thì thực ra là ông chỉ mất một
khoảng thời gian ngắn thôi à Không thể
học xong rồi
anh nghe Chắc là bạn ấy thì có thể thống
nghĩ rồi bạn thì mới học xong rồi cái
cốt lõi thôi chứ để mà học hiểu hết thì
bạn thấy con nhà người ta rồi
mà thực ra tôi vẫn nghĩ là không ai
khẳng định được cái điều đấy nên nó hơi
bị ngược ấy
quá Có phải xong mới vào kênh tôi Tôi
của bị hồn với cảm với tôi tôi phải dậy
như này điểm Nếu không quan tâm chứ cả
tôi không quan tâm thì tiền không ạ Mỗi
người có một nhu cầu riêng tôi không nhu
cầu thì tiền
đơn giản thế thôi
Ok chưa ừ ừ
Công nghệ quản lý cho Z là g-speed và
tôi bỏ qua tôi không truyền ra Speed
lấy coupon code Tân An được chuyên Nó là
kiểu gần trên đấy toàn mấy ông là màu mà
Mấy ông chơi để làm màu ấy là một mẹ hết
sức có thể mới đăng lên trên đấy mấy ông
lên đấy Đúng hiểu toán thật Cốt nó cũng
kiểm cố cũ corsaro trong chuyên nghiệp
nhất có thể cho mày nhất có thể
đến tận buổi thứ Năm rồi hi vọng hôm nay
vẫn cố xong được cho cái gì ở thực ra
thì hôm nay chưa Sắp xong nhớ hôm nay
tôi sẽ nói thêm một cái mới nữa
cho mình mình sẽ nói thêm một cái mới
lắm một cái rất là hay nó động đến chính
cái mà mà mình đã tạo bảng cho nó chứ Đó
là xin Compaq à
khi bé ông nhớ cái cái bảng Con thích
của mình ông ạ
Ê mấy ông nhớ các bạn không thích nhờ
tác dụng để gì không ạ
à à
khi nỗi nhớ cái cái bảng có thích ở điểm
gì
anh alo thôi tập trung vào vấn đề này
ở nhà xem ông nhớ bài nào để chữa
hỗ trợ bật mà trước ở trường tôi có
không không không gọi được cái quay là
gọi nó chưa Ông ấy ở lớp phó chứ ông có
ông lớp trưởng nghỉ thứ rồi
xe Củi khô
yếu
anh alo alo alo
nhiên sinh ra bà này không ạ thì để mình
lưu lại chỗ dạng là tư lại những cả em à
về sau
này để về sau hiển thị lên và bể mình đỡ
phải béo và sửa cốt hay là có giao diện
ở bên Admin để mà giao diện ăn mì chỉ
cần thêm một cái thêm thêm sửa khóa
ngang một gái thì nó sẽ tự động cập nhật
ở mọi chỗ
anh thưởng ở liên quan đến cả cả cả giao
diện hoặc là liên quan đến kiểu cấu hình
gì gì đó Và trong trường hợp này một cái
rất là hay đó chị nhà liên quan đến với
giá này thì ở đây ở đây mấy ông thấy là
hôm trước nó có bài toán này nó xảy ra
ở đây à Tôi là sự cố hiển thị min max
aziz là sợ và quấn sari lên cho béo nhé
thì đây nó có bài toán xảy ra ở đây đó
là cái đồng tiền của tôi đang cho nó có
thể là là
ở đôla Việt Nam Đồng hoặc alo đúng nếu
không nhớ không ạ Thôi nhớ là người chị
cũng mỗi thế thôi chứ bạn xem nha canxi
à À đúng rồi tuần sau cái chẳng ạ chả
thế đúng không ạ
sau đó thì khi mà người ta thêm một bài
mới người ta giả sử người ta chọn đồng
Việt Nam đồng ý Ngạn nó sẽ là xong rồi
người ta cho nin là 10 triệu cho đến 20
triệu đồng Ngoài ra xử thế sau đó đi ở
bên một bài đăng khác thì họ lại chọn
đồng USD đồng đôla sang ngồi lại là
1.000 đến 2.000 đô chẳng ạ thì mình lưu
lại trong ta ta bay là 10 triệu này xong
rồi đồng đôi Việt Nam đồng này đúng ạ
sau đó thì ờ
có 1.000 đô 2.000 đô xong rồi
USD đúng không ạ Nếu thế thì khi mà hiển
thị ra ở bên bên giao diện đây này sau
đó thì người dùng lại Peter theo đồng
Euro nha Trả này thì Rốt cuộc là mình sẽ
phải tính toán để mà Thì chị ra là một
kết hợp việc là thì chị ra cái đồng tiền
tệ ở đây trong nó ra đúng ạ thì cái việc
tính toán kể con phủ nhân thế nào để mà
rủ
Hello ngay đúng không ạ Alo Này nhân với
con số sao cho mà nó sẽ khớp với cái con
số kiểu ra được cái bài đăng đấy thì
mình làm như thế nào thì trả nợ đây mình
sẽ phải lưu lại một khái niệm đó Mình
lưu lại khái niệm tỷ giá Mình sẽ lưu lại
ví dụ là Alo nó là như thế nào so với
đồng tiền kia và vận Em có muốn đi của
tôi đang định nói vấn đề ở đây là như
thế nghĩa mình sẽ lưu lại ở đây là những
cái Đông Mình thực ra thường là sẽ có 2
cách để mà làm điều này
một là ông vẫn cho phép lưu lại ông bạn
sẽ cho phép như lại đồng tiền đồng tiền
ở đây theo đúng cái người dùng chọn cái
mệnh già à cái
số lượng theo đúng như người dùng người
dùng Điền ví dụ là một 10 triệu như tôi
vừa nói đến 20 triệu nhưng tôi phải nói
rằng hạn và đồng tiền viện lao động nhá
đây một cách sau đó thì ông lưu lại tỷ
giá ví dụ Giả sử tỷ giá đây sẽ tỷ giá
giữa Việt Nam đồng với truyền sóng USD
tỷ giá là
11 đối D bằng 20000 chả chán thế không ạ
Đấy
U23 nhìn cho hai 3000 đi đó sau đó thì
khi mà khi mà tìm kiếm ở đây giả sử theo
USD đúng không Thì ông sẽ nhân với
23.000 lên để mà xem con số nó sẽ con sổ
nó sẽ tương ứng như thế nào Cái cái bài
đăng để có thỏa mãn điều đấy không chán
thế
ở đây đấy nó nó sẽ kiểu có ngưỡng kiểu
như thế không
ở đây là một cách 1 cách nữa thì như ở
công ty tôi làm thì cách đấy nó thực à
Nó cũng 50 50 đó ra sao đó là lưu lại
khẳng song.ao bay mình sẽ chỉ lưu lại
cái cái tiền là quét đêm thôi tức là sao
nghĩa và ví dụ là tôi lưu lại là 10
triệu tôi sẽ tôi lúc mà lưu lại trong
đây bế tôi sẽ phải chia nó cho cái tỷ
giá của D là để ra được con số của SD đỡ
nhiên đồng tiền của Canxi Sorry ở đây
tôi lưu là Việt Nam đồng nhá Nhưng mà
lúc này tôi lưu lại vào ra tao bây tôi
lưu lại khẳng là theo kiểu USD thì để
lúc mà mình phiêu tô như này thì không
cần phải tính toán lại một phát nữa bởi
vì cái việc tính toán như thế thì mấy
ông hiểu được là bây giờ mình ông c-rack
trong.ai bay kiểu gì để mà tính đúng ạ
Bây giờ sửa tôi truyền lên là kết quả xử
tôi truyền liên lạc muốn quen là từ 200
cho đến 500 đúng ạ thì rõ ràng mỗi một
bài đăng này nó lại bị một nhược điểm là
mỗi bài đăng này ở lại một đồng tiền
khác nhau thì câu truy vấn của tôi nó sẽ
không phải là kiểu không có khái niệm là
kiểu dạng là sẽ AK
Vì sao
fromsports kiểu ngày đúng ạ Mình sẽ quay
như thế nào Quen ansari ạ
A Gọi lớn hơn 200 à 01 vì rõ ràng là
trong trường hợp này rõ ràng mà đâu phải
là Minh Truyền đây là 200 đô nhưng mà rõ
ràng bài đăng bây giờ lại tiền Việt Nam
đồng cơ mà đối ngoại những kiểu cho ông
khi mình lại phải chia thử hợp ram
trường này Đấy mình sẽ phải 200 này xong
rồi nhân với cái tỷ giá đúng không ạ Nếu
bài đăng nghĩa là mình phải ít theo đoạn
này hoặc case When trong trường là cây
sữa quen là kiểu Nếu mà nếu mà là kiểu
quần xi Sorry em ạ Như này nếu mà ông
muốn biết cụ xảy ra thì đúng kiểu ảnh
như này luôn này ví dụ là bằng một trà
sử bằng một tất cả Việt Nam đồng được ạ
đấy thì cái 200 này 200 mình chửi lên
đấy để ạ Nó sẽ phải nhân và nó sẽ cây
squares cửa nhà tôi sẽ quen giả sử Ví dụ
nhé là 200 nhân với
chủ đề kiểu nhảy đi
23.000 Giả sử thế
xe tải
ạ sau đây còn eo nữa này hòa quen đây
này lại phải lập
Âm Nhạc
Ừ nếu mà là đồng tiền kiểu dạng là đồng
tiền Euro chẳng hạn thì lại phải 200
nhân với 1,6
xong rồi lại Wen tiếp xong ngồi
Anh Tuấn Vân bằng ba nhé này thì 200
nhân về bao nhiêu giả sử như thế nào nhỉ
Tôi không
cho mấy mấy ông hiểu cái loại này của
tôi không nghĩa là nếu mà giả sử mà ông
lưu lại trong database kể con số đẹp mà
con số Giả sử là 10 10 10 triệu rằng ạ
Có cái để đây mười nghìn nhá
anh như này sẽ đồng tiền của tôi là Việt
Nam đồng đúng ạ thì thì khi mà câu truy
vấn của tôi truyền lên 200 USD đối ngoại
thì tôi phải phải hạnh nhân 200 Đấy ra
tiền Việt Nam đồng so với Tôm mới so
sánh được đúng ạ đúng chứ Sau đó thì nếu
mà trường hợp mà cái bà đang đấy lại là
đồng Euro thì tôi lại phải nhân với 1,6
trở lại thế với cái đồng
đồng Yên Đồng gì gì đó thì tôi làm nhân
với tỷ giá nữa bởi vì cái này đòi đồng
USD xong rồi nhân với tỷ giá để nó ra
được đồng tiền của bài đăng đấy em lấy
ít tuổi như thế
thì ông mày thấy mấy cái câu C của ông
có rảnh không ạ kê việc là về sau sẽ rất
khó làm đúng không ạ Nên là Cách thứ 2 ở
công ty tôi đang làm đó là phải chấp
nhận bài toán đó là mình sẽ không hiển
thị đẹp được Kiểu như này
Khi mà mình sẽ hiển thị mà mình sẽ lưu
lại ở đây lưu lại là khái niệm là là
mình sẽ lưu lại thành hết hàng USD để
lưu lại hết thành USD ở trong sân bay
kiểu dạng sử 10 nghìn 10 triệu mình sẽ
quyên góp thành bao nhiêu
dấu phẩy phẩy đương nhiên sẽ có phải
phải ở đây phải phải ở đây sau đó thì
khi mình que thì mình sẽ chỉ quen đơn
giản thôi ông ạ que sẽ đúng kiểu lớn hơn
200 thôi đơn giản không ạ Nhưng khi mà
hiển thị ra ở giao diện thì đúng là mấy
ông thấy phải phẩy như thế trong nó rất
là xấu đúng không ạ thì mình lại nhân
lại với cái tỷ giá ngân lại với cái tỷ
giá xong rồi mình sẽ làm tròn con số ấy
lên thì nó sẽ lại hình đẹp Nếu không
hiểu cho em
cho ví dụ Giả sử tôi Giả sử nhá là sử ví
dụ đâu nha À đây là 10 triệu Việt Nam
đồng tôi lưu lại trong tao bây giờ sự
thành 150usd ra xử thế không ạ đúng ạ
xong 1,5 đi là sử đấy lại như này trong
một xấu Nếu ạ trong xấu khi mày hiển thị
ra ở đây thì tôi lại tôi lại thấy tôi
lại kiểm tra là ừ nói Việt Nam đồng Tôi
sẽ nhân lại nó với tỷ giá rồi tôi sẽ dục
tôi sẽ dùng hàm làm tròn tao sửa làm
tròn hai theo kiểu là đến một đến con số
hàng trăm Hoàng đến hàng nghìn em ạ cứ
nghĩ hàng trăm là đẹp rồi thì nó sẽ làm
tròn lên và trở lại thành con số đẹp để
hiển thị ra cho người dùng nếu hiểu cho
em
Ừ cái này nãy giờ chưa cốt gì cả nhưng
mà nãy giờ đang nói hình dung bài toán
Nếu không hiểu luồng làm việc không anh
anh alo
mấy ông cơ sở Nếu có tải thôi
Nghe bài hát để tôi thử nó lại có hai
cách 2 cách nha Thôi tục kết lại hai cái
nha
ở
trường hợp một này
chờ một là
lưu lại
mã số đẹp số cụ thể số tiền
vào trong top 7 đúng ạ ví dụ sự là lưu
lại cụ thể là 10 triệu hạn đến 20 triệu
và trong đó bây và đồng tiền này là Việt
Nam đâu đúng không ạ Việt Nam đâu đấy
rượu là mưa triệu đến 20 triệu Việt Nam
đâu đúng không ạ thì khi mà mình sẽ like
mình mình were theo kiểu
Anh quay theo kiểu mình truyền lên à 200
cho đến 1.000 đô chẳng ạ đúng ạ
Ai chỉ mình câu xe lách của mình sẽ là
selec
I fall pass cái gì đó đúng không saue
Mình sẽ phải quay ở đây mình sẽ lấy
Sorry này mình sẽ phải so sánh Sari
anh với rất nhiều trường hợp là trong
trường hợp mà nếu mà bạn nếu ở Việt Nam
đồng thì mình sẽ phải 200 nhân với
23.000 đúng trước mà và tương tự Thế
nếu mà kiểu là alo thì mình sẽ ở nhân
với 1.6 đúng chứ
xe đẩy xôi vẫn văn nữa mình có tận 6
đồng tiền là mình sẽ phải 6 cái cây Quen
như thế này mỗi câu select cách sau đó
nó thấy thỏa mãn hay không thỏa mãn ra
xử nó thỏa mãn lên nữa nó lại duyệt tiếp
dòng tiếp theo và cứ thế cứ thế Kể cả
không thỏa mãn thì nó vẫn Diệt phần
thích heo những giờ xử đây đang có mỗi
82 thời gian mà ít thôi nhưng mà tán
Minh Khai nhân với
6 cái sức khỏe à
xuất cây để mà kiểu kiểm tra xem là là
kiểu
có thỏa mãn hay không có Vân không thấy
giữ cân nặng thai bị như thế mình sẽ có
trường hợp thứ 2 trường hợp 2
và không lưu
chỉ cụ thể số tiền đúng ạ Mình sẽ lưu 10
triệu này mình sẽ đổi thành USD giả sử
dã sử thôi Nó là một 99,999 phạm nguyên
98299 nhìn này là sự rất xấu thành đô rê
như thế này là xử thế 10 triệu thành của
con số ngay
khi mình sẽ lách cửa nhà mình sẽ rất là
đơn giản thì sẽ chỉ sẽ lách thẳng lớn
hơn 200 nhà được không ạ bởi vì mình
chưa lên 200 thì mình sẽ chỉ cần xe lách
lớn hơn 200 xử thế ông ạ Nhưng mà mấy
ông sẽ thấy là khi mình in ra ở giao
diện này trong nó xấu bởi vì một là mình
đi con số của 2 6 2 Ngân lại vào thì khi
mà chia ra kiểu này nó sẽ đi lẻ rồi khi
nhân lại vào thì nó có thể này là đại
hơn nó sẽ không hẳn là 10 triệu nữa nó
sẽ kiểu
9,999 như thế này là xử thế là sự thế
khi thì mình sẽ dùng cái hàm để mà làm
tròn thành con số hàng nghìn hoặc có số
hàng trăm mình sẽ kiểu làm tròn lên
nên làm tròn lên thôi chắc là chẳng có
làm chẳng sướng đâu Lúc mình lưu lại thì
mình sẽ lưu lại là làm trọ Mình sẽ lưu
lại đến con số cậu ở trung học flash nên
thành ra nó sẽ số khá là kiểu phẩy phẩy
phẩy anh vào nó sẽ ăn kiểu gì tôi nghĩa
nó sẽ ăn bớt theo cậu nó làm tròn xuống
Sau đó mình chỉ việc làm tròn lên đánh
con số Nói chung gần nhất để mà kiểu nói
nhưng thì ra con số thành làm cho nên 20
triệu được
Ok chứ
Ừ nếu nhiều cho em thì đây là cách thứ 2
ở công ty là
cách 1 thì mấy ông nhìn thấy tờ ông có
bao nhiêu đồng tiền nó dễ chia lần này
cái cây thích cây này mỗi câu c lách của
ông vỡ mồm không ạ
anh hoặc chị đã giảm cách đơn giản hơn
nó không không cho kiểu Peter theo cái
này nữa theo hướng dẫn nhất nhưng mà
không Chúng ta không không làm thế không
ạ chúng ta thấy có bài toán khó là chúng
ta nghĩ cách giải quyết nhưng mà không
làm nữa buông ông ạ
và tiếp theo đó là thế làm thế nào để ra
được con số Min và có số mắt ngay từ lúc
đầu như thế này thì có hai cái khay
trường hợp có thể làm một mà ông sẽ lấy
luôn nhi seri ở trong bảng post này để
máu lấy giống như hôm trước tôi lấy toàn
bộ City do mày đấy Thực ra tôi thấy là
kiểu đấy không không nên nó lắm Bởi vì
rõ ràng là bìa mình áp dụng cho trường
hợp Thứ hai này đó là là con số nó bắn
mình không lưu cụ thể số tiền nên con số
mean ở trong này nó sẽ có thể này lẻ nó
rất là xấu thế nên là tôi thích theo
kiểu dạng là tự ăn mi mình quy ước là
cái Min này vào mắt mày thế nào cho đẹp
Ừ đúng ạ Chứ không phải nè Này mấy ông
có nhận lúc lẻ trong mà xấu đấy thì thì
cái lưu lại cài MIMAX đấy mình cũng sẽ
lưu ở trong con fix này mình giờ sửa
Twitter Min giá trị là 100 này ạ Cái to
mắt giờ chị là 1.000 và đôi nhân áo mới
đây rồi không ạ Đấy sau đó thì đương
nhiên à người dùng không kéo hơn 1.000
Thực ra ở Bình mình quý hiếm như thế
Thật ra nó hạn chế trong đây giống hãnh
diện người dùng muốn tìm kiếm hơn 1.000
Tìm kiếm được chiếu khi người dùng Chơi
bẩn à mình mình đẩy lên trong thanh địa
chỉ cái cái này là kiểu là 1.000 người
dùng sửa lại trên này 2.000 3.000 gì đó
ra vẫn quay theo rồi đấy mà vẫn ra như
còn thanh kéo của mình nó sẽ chỉ có giới
hạn đến money thôi Ừ nếu hiểu cho
xe tải Viber
Bởi vì tôi chưa làm giao diện của cái
con fix này nên tôi thể quyết thẳng luôn
hot in sát thẳng luôn là không bênh anh
nhá mình sẽ in sót là giọt sự lại ờ À
môi và tiện thể tôi muốn nói luôn một tí
về bảo mật đó là cái con vích này như
mày Ông vừa nghe thì rõ ràng là tôi sẽ
loát cái con thích này ra ở bên bên đây
gọi là home page hoặc cả kiểu à Cậu cần
nhiều trang thủ cái trang văn trang hiện
fanpage vẽ tranh ở bên giao diện mà bến
khách hàng thế nên là phụ nữ Tuy One
Piece có phải con thích về sau là ông
phải con nít trong cốt trà sửa tỷ giá
hay các thứ thứ chiếu không nên hiển thị
ra bên giao diện với khách hàng không
lót nó ra đấy Hà không ạ thì mình có thể
quy ước nó như sau mình sẽ thêm một cột
ở đây nữa của level hoặc một file level
nghe hợp lý nghĩa làm chỉ là level tất
cả tưởng rằng là
Anh thường hay ở kiểu mình level kiểu đi
bộ không thức cám Chị ở nó là nó là của
public còn level 1 tất cả ám chỉ phải
five chẳng hạn Hiểu Chị Hiển thị ở chị
Loan ở miền Bắc em thôi bên form không
được phép hiển thị ra nếu nghỉ đâu em
đấy em mình theo quy giúp nó vỡ Thế
nếu mà Giả sử có mỗi 2 level đấy thử ca
Tôi nghĩ là Lê vâng ạ Cho như thế này
tên nó là kìa ít ít bơ Ken à Kiều Kiều
thế hay ít hè suy Quyết Hạ hoặc Cả in
public tôi sẽ mục thêm một cái cột nữa
is public xong
ông nào hiểu được hiểu nhé nên là thành
ra nó hơi bị khó đúng
I eat stop leak này
Chỗ khi mà tên là ít cả nhà thì sẽ hiểu
nó là buôn lần dạng buôn lần cạo chua
phone không ạ ạ
cho anh Rõ ràng ở thêm
3 bài tập bài
sẽ cắt thứ thứ cái cá nhiều rất nhiều
file máy Vision
con ếch này à
nay thì mọi thứ nó nhanh hơn hẳn Nhưng
mà
Em cảm thấy thật là thiếu thốn khi mà
không có cái gợi ý gì cả
Không chờ nạn
khi chọn gợi ý cả Buồn lắm à
à Nó đây mình đã thêm một cột nữa
ông Lê cô chỗ mặc định là kiểu in public
bây giờ sửa là thì sẽ có Trường là
Trường à Peter
một ta 100 đô bèo mà mình sẽ cho là thật
sự là 200 đô nhỉ
- 200 đô
- 200 đô là hơn 4 triệu rồi
Ẩm Thực tập viên à thực tập thực tập 4
triệu
có một triệu
Ừ ừ mean nghe Nó hiểu bé bé bình thường
mà phải bảy tám triệu đúng không bảy tám
triệu là sẽ 300 đô ở 300 đô
Ừ
cái này đó xóa đói một cái là mắt
a mắt cho hẳn lên đến 2.000 đi
mắt cái season graphic này ở bên A bên
kia là xong
khi đó ngoại mình sẽ lát cái con fix này
sau đó mình chị ở bên A
Lý Nhã Vy đúng nhỉ Không phải Nó là cái
size 3
ừ ừ
thì mình sẽ lát cái này ra mình sẽ ở đây
có cái là
anh phi tơ
a solari
Để tôi xem nhé bây giờ như thế này
Tôi đang nghĩ là mình bởi vì bản chất là
phải public sẽ luôn được rót ra Đợi tí
Đợi tí nhé đầu tiên tôi cổ cái thằng con
vích
đi mua đồ cũng thích này tôi sẽ
tạo nó một cái Hàn là ghét em cách
anh như này ờ
Ý là mình sẽ truyền ở đây là kiểu ít
public tưởng ngay
thì mình sẽ đi tên ở đây sẽ lên bờ mình
cái kia của nó sẽ là
nghỉ ngồi một cái xin cái key ở đây mình
sẽ đây có là à
a system ở đây compete thôi
Em thích như này
à à
À
mà đây sẽ ra system config
Ừ cái kia ông thích này và mình sẽ
truyền thêm một cái nữa lại ít spudnik
như thế này
Ừ Nó là kiểu dạng nhà có không ấy tiếp
theo là mình sẽ tư lại là
E400 nhân với 30 chẳng hạn tiếp theo là
phương trình ngay bản chất là mình sẽ
trả về ở đây là mình sẽ cái thằng con
fix này thì mình sẽ dùng Zip được mình
sẽ
Ừ tôi sẽ dùng sáng tất cả đây đi
ở đây độ file không còn thích này vào
tôi sẽ ghi tên ở đây là sale là tất cả
chính chính cái thằng mua đồ con thích
này nhá chị sẽ gọi quay ở đây mình sẽ
que
lại yêu
this pic này sao mình sẽ que ít
a public
Em chuyền in speak vào trong những ai
rồi mình sẽ ghét lấy toàn bộ ngay
cái con cái con fix này mình sẽ chị và
nó tự đậm cách lại thì sẽ chỉ gọi ngay
thôi ấy và đặt tên lại sẽ không thích
ngay
anh cái thẻ xong
em mặc định ở đây sẽ truyền là à phone
phone nó sẽ bằng với không nhá Fulham
trường này bằng không Rồi ai cái thằng
như nhau vậy đúng nhỉ
Ừ đúng nhỉ
I phone
040 ý nghĩa bằng nhau như này nó chắc đi
đấy à
a tiếp theo là mình kia có con thích này
rồi thì mình chuyển là mình chuyển sang
bên ai thôi
A One Piece đó từ bên size 3 mình sẽ là
ở đây cho này xuống dòng nhìn nó rõ nhé
thì mình sẽ đây đó con fix gọi đến
là
I live Alone này thì tôi sẽ gọi nó theo
giản là đây Tôi sửa lại đây một tí ở đây
sẽ có cái có được sân là có data đúng
không
Ê nó lấy ra như này tôi muốn ở đây là
tôi muốn sẽ xét
khi nó biến hình ma cái này cái thằng
này nó sẽ đến màn theo kiểu là chi của
nó và lu nó như thế này nó sẽ có một cái
ơi ở đây cho chồng nhớ ai sofex ở đây
a data mày các em à
ex5
ạ sau đó thì lại ở đây truyền x tại
dollar à Tại thi sẽ bằng ích tại và lù
ngay cơ
ạ sau đó mình sẽ đi tên cả rồi như thế
này
ở đây mình sẽ trả về đây cũng khá rồi
luôn
Ừ để tôi hiểu được là tôi trả về nó sẽ
đúng kiểu nhà này tôi cho mình không xem
nhé
số đề con thích à à
ở đó thì sẽ hết trả về kiểu đúng kiểu
Nga
Ừ để mình khi mình in ra ở bên bên này
thì mình sẽ in ra kiểu dạng ngay thôi
A gọi đến
Twitter Min như này
khi đồng đôla đúng
gì tương tự thế với lại thế
đang lấy á từ ra Swift của mình mình sẽ
được sửa lại bên ra Speed nữa để ra
Swift Vì thực tế à mình ha cốt thế là
sai
anh méo nhớ về đại ra ký tự nhiên nói
cho hành 8 80 đó là bốn này đúng không
hay nó đoạn này
ở đây này cái này nó nằm ở đâu nhỉ Tí
xem lại như Master vậy
ở đây đây đây
start này sai đấy bỏ Mimax đi trở lại
anh không biết có chạy được không
à à
Vì
sao không có anh
Ừ nếu không thì mình sẽ lấy minmax từ
chính cái à Ai đi mình sẽ đặt tên thằng
này ai đi để cho nó lấy được ở đây file
rito quay lai này sẽ lấy theo cái thằng
đấy đây
khác trong vãi chưởng nhỉ bạn bên này
dùng really này không dùng Anh hiểu à
nụ hôn tonight cause tonight
khi bật sử và trước đi
nhà mình cần lấy cái à
máy tách màu nó
Anh remix
Ừ đi lại nhanh
ở ngã rẽ sang
a ngoặc
này mình sẽ có step là chấm hết Tách
ngay sẽ lấy đúng với giá trị
À mà đấy xe à y như thế này là sao
a grammar Friends chủ nghĩa tăng lên à
có hợp âm luôn nhỉ Mình để ở đây chắc
không nhầm đâu
anh đã không thể quá thành âm được cộng
đây cộng nhà
A500 đi
Ừ ok tiếp theo ở đây sẽ
trò chuyện này vào được
em tắt đi
khi tách giống nhà
Ừ thôi cứ để hát về một đầu cha vẫn được
đấy thế thử nhé Thì rõ
sao không nói được
ừ ừ
đúng rồi nên dùng cái thekken Tank hơn
khi nơ HTML
A gọi đến hợp Tech nhưng có phải nó vẫn
ra
anh vẫn ra cái khoảng trống
thì tại sao mà sao không lấy được một hệ
số là nó bị nó bị à
mình sẽ châu Á thì lấy số ở trong thực
này thì như thế nào
ừ ừ
có size 3 Star
không cần phải lấy lại cái này tôi muốn
à bản chất là cái này nó sẽ gần như
không thay đổi rồi Xóa sư cái đi thì sẽ
có span ở đây nhanh là xong Đây là flash
schoolnet
Ừ đợi tí nhé
ở spa nữa đây
Xong rồi Có ai đi đây à
I spent này mình mới thì mới cần à
khi nãy
vì thế tránh thêm khoảng trống thì tôi
sẽ để hẳn ngay đi đó sẽ như này may cái
à Xóa đi
ở đó tưởng tượng Huế với thằng cái này
sẽ dai đúng không ạ Ở đâu à
anh nghe day này vào đây xem mắt
xóa đi Ừ còn em Master mình sẽ là file
it
em lấy ra được Giá Rai like ra giá con
cái này để in nó ra thì ở
Ừ cái lao Mắc cái này
Anh ở được
ca nhạc rồi thế này được
anh vang Note mắm nem bridge Tại sao nhỉ
vì đ
à à
chị xem nha à
Ừ đúng rồi
- thì nó vẫn là
I - nó vẫn là số nhưng mà cậu này nó
họ đậu xanh à
chưa bé nói xấu nó thích ông cộng được
gì game dễ
thành 2.500 đấy nhỉ
có về không được rồi anh chết đi
ừ ừ
khi sex
em bị người ngon
Tôi
ở tập tí nhá rồi con số 800 nhỉ
Happy stone nó là Exciter mà
Ừ chứ không cộng 500 này
chuỗi
họ
đậu xanh đổi lại phải chơi chỗ kia rồi
anh khó chịu nghỉ à ờ ờ
khi Violet
à à
ừ ừ
luôn cả chuỗi của mình đi ạ vãi cả
chưởng
phẩy phẩy như này mình thấy quy ước cái
thằng nhà thằng Ui
này gì nhỉ
à à
cô Nguyễn Thị Quý gốc nhá Nó nó khi mở
kéo ấy thì nó sẽ
đã test cài đặt ạ
Anh kéo nó chỉ được lắp nhảy 50 đô tại
một thời điểm rồi ông không kéo Cầu
Giảng bài thì thận một vài đô như thế
trong ổ Bình cười
Anh Hải ơi mẹ ông theo 50 độ Ừ nó chị
làm sao
Tải game dễ tượng vi đàn bà
à À quên nãy giờ mình đang làm nó hơi bị
sai đấy sai đấy Đó là mình hả lấy cái
này À như này
thì mình phải có cái inbox hay đơn ở đây
và mình sẽ lấy dữ liệu từ máy in Pad 2
lần này mới đúng nãy là tôi làm bà sao
đoạn này nó cứ sai sai cái hiển thị nãy
lời thì cho vui chứ mình ấn suất bây giờ
có sơn được lâu thì rõ ra là mình bị đâu
có mình có trả pháo động gì tới thằng
này phải thì mình ở đây mình sẽ có input
hai đơn vị
Min Syria ở nhà ừ ừ
mắt
a mắt này
Ê bà đây Ở đây bây giờ làm nóng chuẩn
này ở đây là mình sẽ có ID
Anh thường mình sẽ đặt tên kiểu ngày nó
sẽ là input
ờ ờ
a price
khi họa mi mi mi Serie A
anh ở đây sẽ spar
u-turn spam ah
à
mình làm kiểu gì làm bị sai sai rồi
Em nấu xong
vnsharing OOO
anh Bằng
men Serie A
số 2.3 lu này
ở nhà nó mới đúng này
son Mac ở đây là mắc này
ạ
sau đó đi ỉa
các clip day này không phải chậm lắm
ở bến xe khuất hẳn toilet ra ở đây bên
này luôn à
a mansory 2 massage ở đây này
ở lại mất Sorry ở đây
vì đ
ở nhà xong
cả ngày không có trạm lắm không trọng
lắm
a nice dream exces
Hôm nay tôi sẽ có một cái à
ốp lát ở đây là lúc ta ở đây đi
Ê
bà đây sẽ bằng đoạn này
sẽ bằng 3
A và
Em in both methods
ba sẽ bằng 3 ngay tương tự Thế đây là
Min Ah
I mean
So sánh ai đi ok này
Ừ rồi Còn ở bên này thì à
cô giáo sư Xoay đi
anh trả xong rồi thử nhé
ở đó ok chưa xịn nhớ đưa nhau phải chọn
lại cái này đúng không Thì mình sẽ chưa
làm mình trở lại thôi mình sẽ kiểm tra
là
ờ ờ Nếu mà chuyền in chuyện mắc lên thì
mình sẽ đi đề vào cái hàng này
em ở xa mà con fix này
em không thích vẫn mặc định lấy ra từ
Cách Không sao cả Nhưng nếu thế mình sẽ
có là
mình sẽ ưu tiên lấy từ trên thanh địa
chỉ ở trước đó là quét Nếu mà ghét cái
Win7
Miss J thế này nếu mà không có thì mình
mới lấy từ con Fix là như này defoe là
là nếu không có mình sẽ lấy tôi con
thích kiểu như này là xong
tương tự thế mắc lắm thế
em làm mắt lại là mắt cho nó đi tôi
truyền vào đây là à Mắc min đây
I mean Suri nhảy và massage
làm in saree này à
thế này sẽ là
a Mắt Ngọc
à à
a750 anh Tư đúng bị nhược điểm mà không
thấy ở đây nó Nó đang bị nó đang bị biến
hàng à Gì à
vì nó không cho nhỏ hơn lại so với cái
số cũ giống nhau ở Đống mà không nghe
nhỏ hơn lại so với số cũ
Ừ để xem nhé mình nên có một cái Điệp
Mình vẫn lên truyền sang cái
you can pick nhỉ
Ừ mình vẫn lấy con fix để lấy cái đèn
phô
Chị Thơ nghĩa vẫn sẽ phải chuyển sang
cái phô
ở đây à
thẳng để phô ở trong này
đây không nên kiểu truyền thẳng vào như
thế này
anh không
a quiet thực tế không nên chiến thắng p
vào trong The Switch Cho dù vẫn làm được
vẫn làm được kiểu nhà nhờ không không
lên rồi
có thể xuống anh 200 không ạ Con sẽ
không bị lỗi gì cả
ở đó
Ừ mẹ không bị lỗi nhà hôm nay làm nhưng
mà hi vọng với ông hiểu Nãy giờ tôi đang
làm gì thôi à
ý nghĩa trọn minmax này đương nhiên là
mình sẽ kiểu lấy trong cái giới hạn này
đúng ạ
đề thi cái đây tôi vừa nãy tôi nói đó
giá sự là tiền của mình
a tiếp theo đến cái đoạn khó hơn về cái
xe lách thực sự tiền lại nóng lạnh thì
mình đang quy ước ở đây tiền của mình là
như thế nào tiền của mình là Việt Nam
đồng là cái đầu tiên em ạ Đấy giờ sự thế
giờ tôi sẽ thử là sự số toàn đi là sự
cầu toàn đi
ừ ừ
Khi
mà mình sẽ
em chia 10 10 triệu
một triệu 10 triệu
2.000 3.000 ngày đúng không ạ
vì sao số anh đúng chứ có thể nó không
đúng lắm nó kêu nó lại lẻ này đúng ạ à
a Mimax của mình là
Vì sao Mimax Mình ở ba chai này
10 đến mình làm cái gì là tại sao biết
mình ba tra rồi Này để heo
hiển thị tương đội đội tuyển dữ liệu nó
hyflat để đội luận được cả cái này đã
cái này phải để nó là mình nên để nó là
số của mình đang lưu lại lại đi 5
Ừ ừ rõ Làng Tôi Không nhớ Hồi đấy tôi
làm gì nữa Đúng rồi
enter Bloom
Bin nói chung ở
Em in posts table
Vì
sao bị để nó là trans
ừ ừ
a boss
ở đây là mansory
chị sẽ để nó thành à
The Flash
không Mình sẽ tất cả hàng ngày vào trong
này
anh không cần root
Devil trong chẳng có cái iPhone nào đây
cả trên ở đây thay đổi flash flash và
cũng tương đối đấy mà để đắp bồ cho chắc
cũng được tớ nghĩ để flash thôi
ở đây nếu mà có thì mình sẽ trên nó
tương tự với mắt sẽ đi và tương tự với
ah
ở Sorry quần xi là inter cho trên đĩa
xong nó dễ Mã
cho nó xong rất nhanh rất nguy hiểm đó
mình đã có số Thấy bảo mình thì chuẩn số
này sau đó tôi sẽ lưu lại con số này vào
xem được không nhé
à à
tiếp theo mình sẽ lên hàng Thái mới
triệu
thể biến lên nó sẽ bị phẩy phẩy rồi
không tin nhắn lại nhanh nha
à à
đúng đâu Nếu nó sau nhân được
ở con số 3 này mà làm tròn lên thành
20 triệu được vớ vẩn đó ngon số 3 này nó
chậm nhân 23 đồ vật điều đấy này
ở con số 5 Này có nhân nghe còn hợp lý
chắc chắn có số bài khó mình phải ba này
có thể nhân lên thành 20 triệu này được
đúng ạ lừa sẽ là lừa luôn
ừ ừ
dùng hàm làm tròn mà không phải lo gì cả
nhưng đại khái như thế thì sẽ thì sẽ
kiểm tra
mình sẽ kiểm tra
và lấy đấy ra con số hợp lý con Bây giờ
Bây giờ đầu tiên mình chỉ whey thôi
nhưng mà thôi chưa nhập cái gì đấy cả
chưa quay cả nếu mà mình muốn quay mình
sẽ kiểu
anh bắt chước kiểu ngay
à à
Ừ kiểu gì khi truyền lên ở đây sẽ có Min
và mắt Sorry rồi chứ không có trường hợp
với kiểu
em không có nhưng mà đây
a Mystery hỏng Madrid ông ạ
ở cái gì
có tội sao có ở trường hợp nó lại lẻ lại
không có nghĩa là sự người dùng là tự
nhiên xóa bạn đi khiến nó bị lỗi em nhỉ
đây luôn luôn có kiểu dáng này rồi
à à Để rồi xem nhé Nếu mà như thế này
thì
em không được
thì mình sẽ cụ thể như này đúng
Ý là nếu mà
Anh đi quét có min a z
h series
cái này nói chuẩn này
Ừ thì mình sẽ mới lấy cái đúng cái min
là để mình que à
anh về nha à
Ý mình là
a where
thế này anh hoặc là luôn xe min series
thì 26 tương tự thì về mắt
à à
Anh
ở thế sao
Ừ thế thử nha à
vì mấy bài đăng này chủ yếu là Mimax gì
đó để đúng rồi Tôi quên mất là bây giờ
bé đang của tôi sẽ hiển thị ra cái á
Mimax luôn Nó bên tay phải này ở dưới
cùng tôi muốn là như thế thì ở đây
Ừ mình cũng trước mình làm đã ở đây là
mình đã làm hiệu cậu là
A Better của mình không có gì cả
Ừ nếu có cậu con ni mấy hình chị ra
anh ở bên này xem đây cái này như này
ơi mình có một cái đíp vào đít nữa thì
sẽ còn một cái đít vào đây nữa
Đó là kiểu ở
thì mình sẽ hiển thị ra tiền tệ không ạ
Mình sẽ đây là đô reports
rồi gọi đến cái bài toán ở đây là để màn
hình chị đã tiền tệ thì tôi đang muốn
nhìn thị ra như tôi vào bảng thì nó sẽ
phải là vừa nhân vào cái tỷ giá kết hợp
với việc và là
khi mở nhạc ngắn tỷ giá là sao nhỉ và
hiển thị Min và mắc Nếu có đúng ạ thì
tôi đã bảo không nên xử lý dài dòng Ở
Đây Rồi xử lý ở trong mua đồ
mình sẽ có một cái phong chân để mà cậu
ghét ATP cái tỷ giá thư da thực tế nhá
là mấy ông nên để cái
Ê mày cả htpu này
có phải nằm dưới sau cả cài Vision ship
nên lên như thế nên là gì đấy
xe tải
thì mình sẽ có một cái đây là ghét ta
a day thôi chẳng
a solid nghỉ à
là như thế này mình sẽ xử lý như nó
xe tải satxi người đúng nãy mình sẽ đầu
tiên ở đây mình sẽ kiểm tra nếu mà nếu
mà cái này
xu hướng gia là nếu mà trống thì bỏ qua
đúng không ạ
hôm nay mình sẽ có một cái số trình như
thế này chồng nha ít
à à
sao nó luôn ở đây Zip mansory này
Ừ
nhớ mà không trống thì mình sẽ ghi vào
trong cái chuỗi này
đó là truyền vip mansory
anh không gọi gì cả Buồn vãi đái
à à
ừ ừ
đợi tí nhé
ạ sau đó thì nếu mà
Văn Định muốn là kiểu gạch ngang xong
rồi mất Sorry nhưng mà đúng nhỉ thường
là nên in kiểu gì nhỉ Xem nhé ở top CB
mà ở
ở Hà cầu
ở đáy chậu gạch ngang như này trên 15
triệu trong trường hợp mà
chỉ có mỗi Min Tới 15 triệu Nếu trong
chiều có người mắt không ạ Nó không hiểu
không sẽ chia 3 trường hợp Nó kiểu ở
dạng là nếu có cả hai Nếu có kiểu Min
rồi nếu có cả mắt ông ạ
chị sẽ có một xấu như nay
xong rồi đây sẽ là a mắt sinh nhật
làm mất masteri
Xin chào lại đi
khi đó ngoại
con lợn e-i-e-i-o tiếp nếu mà
Ừ có gì nó sẽ là như thế này
ở nhà sao mà
Ừ hi sinh ê
Ừ chắc không cần Neo đoạn này lắm
có không này a tiếp tục nếu không thì
như này
Ừ ok ok
toán xuôi một tí đi đoạn này tôi làm bài
toán nó bị ngược quá à
Xuôi xuôi một tí cho nó trong có vẻ mượt
mà mình đầu tiên là bị kiểm tra đúng
không mình kiểm tra tiên là cả hai thằng
trước đi
Ừ mình chia trường hợp kiểm tra cả hai
thằng đi
à à
thì mình sẽ phải in ra cái kiểu kiểu à
a
Golden Sea của nó cái gì à
a&p này simple đấy à
A và
Ừ nhưng mà đây lấy simple rồi sao còn
phải à
chuyển số vào nữa xem hiển thị nó ra
chính xác như thế nào
biểu tượng mà còn phải hiển thị ra cụ
thể là nó nằm ở đằng trước hay đằng sau
nữa cơ Nếu nghĩ tôi không bạn tôi đang
đang muốn làm nó còn phức tạp hơn một tí
như thế nào chứ
không
vi phạm sóng Trần Đông
thuê chạy vào bên Tết nhỉ
Đấy do mấy ông nên có cái cách cắn cho ờ
ờ ờ
a number format to này lấy từ đâu vậy
a number phó Master
ừ ừ
vị trí ngày được thì phải
Ừ Ok cũng được ở trên thêm à
Ừ rồi
em
có luôn bạn này
ý cho chuyển số vào thì nó ra thử nhé
à à
ở
lại chùa mỗi symbol thôi
Ê xuyên nghe được à
không ạ thì mình sẽ lấy được con số chị
nào thủ nhà mình Lâm Đồng này à
mất rồi ở đâu lúc kết này sẽ thay đổi ý
a vnes i
con chó nó lại xin lỗi
về bản chất bà nếu mà nếu mà thế thì
mình sẽ phải ở đây là ờ ờ
Ừ nhưng mà mình lấy lô kết
Ừ ok ở đây mình sẽ phải
Ừ tôi đã nghĩ là lưu lại còn Shisha là
A là
ô chữ để ở Việt Nam đồng ạ sau đó thì
bên này mình sẽ lưu lại là đúc kết ra
sao
Ừ để cho nó Ánh sang cho nó hợp lý
sẽ lấy ra được con số
ở quần xi
này
Vì sao là chính nói nhé
những chuyện kỳ lạ xong ngay à
trước đêm cái Mochi là
a shelf
ở Lâm Đồng nhiều ạ
Ừ thì mình sẽ
Ê pete ơn về vi
bien trước
Ừ
chắc là thằng này sẽ truyền trả về sự
Trinh à
the best local đã tiếp theo
Ê bà cái được
anh ở đâu biết đây à
là
à mà là anh ấy không muốn nhìn thì ra
chọn đồng tiền ở đây mà lạ
thì mình sẽ hiển thị ra theo đúng cái
giá tiền mà người dùng đã quyết lúc đầu
kiểu không
người người dùng quyết lúc đầu để nhìn
cho số đẹp vì em mình rung không có thể
người dùng quyết lúc đầu nó hẳn hàm lá
kiểu đồ nhiên để hiểu được công ty công
ty của Nhật thì sao không Mình vẫn có
thể tôn trọng nó mình sẽ hiện language
nó không liên quan lâu kết nó không liên
quan gì cả cái tiền người dùng đối đầu
quý ốc thì nó có thì chị đúng rồi đấy
chứ
về đấy
hôm trước
À hôm trước tôi làm là gì nhỉ
Ừ nó là tôi tôi chia sẻ cái mẹ ở bên ra
cái này
sẽ trả về như thế này trả về như này
sống biết ơn họ ngay đây là sẽ
em sửa lại máy tính A1 là Skype ở ngay
đúng không Hay là
nhà mình đấy sẽ có một mạng đúng không
mạnh là lúc kết này ngủ chưa
a cho mình sẽ có phải cái thằng này
thì nó sẽ là phí vn
Ừ cái
ở ngay
à Xong rồi với usd
ở xã n nhé sau đó thì ông sẽ Return về
nó là lâu kết tại vị trí cho kỹ ngay
ở đó
Ừ ông hệ cho nên hỏi chấm hỏi chấm đề
phổ đây nữa là n web Giả sử Trong trường
hợp mà cái cái cột cool seri này nó nôn
thì kia nó sẽ không có nó chắc không ai
trường hợp với đâu
một cách và ông dùng xích cay có này thì
ra sức Ai của này nó lại trong 1 phút
Tao chủ nghĩa dùng kiểu này trong đẹp
nhất này hoặc là hôm trước tôi bảo là
mấy ông nên chọn một hoặc hai cháu hỏi
chọn hại hai cái tôi thích cho mày hơn
kiểu này nó là thực sự Cái này mới lúc
Apple trong cái cái này Nhờ cái này còn
nhận mấy ông nhìn thấy hơi bị xóa nó mới
mình sẽ dùng cái này vậy
n oke cây đúng nhỉ
em không nhớ mày lắm đó nha
ờ ờ vậy
Ừ Tra hạn trên mạng là được đô
à à
ừ ừ
Cái này chắc à
a channel thế
Có ai đi
Ừ đúng
bộ phim xã thế
a Chinese Channel
được thôi chắc ở không ai đăng cái này
đâu đấy ví dụ trong trường hợp như thế
này thì mình sẽ
a report slna phim sẽ
thì mình sẽ đây Có khi là
sợ là
chị đã sửa nha Boss
á quân Sea Nam này kém đồng chẳng hạn
thế
sau đó đi kỳ sẽ là
a vital key cho mình xem nhé
ở chợ đâu nha à
Ừ nó ra Việt Nam đồng Ok chưa nó sau đó
thì lấy lâu kết
đi bằng bus
có gì này ghét nó kết quả kia này chuyện
kia ở trong đây này
thì nó sẽ ra được
A lô kết
khi họ
Ai chả biết
xe
Honda phinx gì đây
Hà Nội Tôi nói tôi ngồi Thế con tiện hơn
sẽ đây là anh alo cái này rồi
ờ ờ
Ừ nhưng mà ở đây sẽ là lấy bay bảo lưu
sau đó chị chưa
a tiếp nha đổi thủ nha
à à ở đó quá ngon alo
alo Ok chứ ngon chưa
từ khóa hợp lý
ừ ừ
anh chị nghỉ hả
ế quá xin rồi nữa nó còn hiển thị đa số
đẹp mà nói ông ạ
ăn cơm chưa
em nằm cốc cốc thần thánh
em
ngủ trưa à
kiếm mỗi chỗ này thì tiền
Ừ lấy luôn kìa à rất là ngày thẳng vào
trong thằng này được luôn không cần lại
chỗ khác nữa nhỉ
thì đôi Cái này là Đô La Gi
ở quần xi
kashiwa-shi Sorry I
à à
ngồi lấy ra truyền vài Đi về như này đây
kìa đồng tiền đấy Cái đồng tiền đó sẽ
chuyển về nó sẽ là mình tĩnh bình tĩnh
bình tĩnh
tiền ở đây ở mình sẽ
Cha Mẹ 8 in cả mắt
Ừ nếu có tí nhé
ừ ừ
as it will sell i i
ông
ngoại mất cái này vào đây nè
thế này thì mình sẽ có
mansory chứ
tiếp theo là
a mắt nóng
tất cả Min
ông bà và
ổ cắm mắt thì sao
em làm kiểu đơn giản gì vậy
thì mình sẽ có Return về
mansory này nối chuỗi với
maxilla này là sự ngay là sự ngay
em ở nhà xong
I fall Đà Nẵng à
em ở đâu nếu ông muốn để tiếng Anh ở đây
dọn sẽ là sẽ là
A AB cả tiếng Anh và tiếng Việt thì sẽ
là có
hai thùng cà lang nhỏ
áo len Đợi tí Đợi tí mình sẽ
3 cách Translate Translate trên iOS
Ừ nếu nhớ nào mình sẽ tạo một cái
thì mình sẽ tạo một cái đây để nó bắt
chước giống như thằng đấy à Có actuelle
à Xong rồi từ bao nhiêu gì đó
Ừ cái này làm gì mà lâu thế nhỉ
thêm có vài cái mới mà đúng không hi
vọng với không bị choáng
I grew Up and place season
anh xóa Facebook
Em ăn Tết
có ai
v-app Key
chị không nhập mình sẽ
An đăng ký rồi à
nhập ở đây nhìn trông nó kiểu to te
quiero quá à
Âm Nhạc
I from
ừ ừ
Sorry đi
em nè
từ từ
à à
phải rõ ràng nó không dùng từ từ đúng
không
top cv
ở trên
em thấy cái tuổi ấp Tú vui Tôi nhớ rồi
Nhưng mà tiếng Anh nhỉ nhập for mà đúng
sẽ là trên đúng không nghe phản bội thật
Okay tiếp nhau ạ đăng nhập sẽ là à
a tu Sari
vì nó rất Pamper
Em hãy ở đây sẽ là ừ
à à
anh tới tới chị mãi anh tới ok
cô gái Tablet học
Ừ hỏi xong Online
Ừ cái này sẽ có Fanpage có cái trên tới
không
sẽ là nếu em chưa Hôm nay mình sẽ có
chuyên vào
Ừ cái loa One Piece I
khi
con nối vào cái này thế là xong
chỉ cách nhau bởi dấu cách nữa
à à
bữa nay sẽ là mắc đúng không Massage I
dù kẻ tu from solid
Ừ nó trả về
I see What cảm nhận
solid ở đây
khi nhìn lại nha à
lỗi gì
em không có cảm in cả mắt đúng không có
cả miệng và mắt thì đúng à Nó trả về nó
là trống thật
về đây là thật rõ đi à
à à
không có cái nào có tiền à Rồi
Hôm nay có tiền mà
ở Bình Dương rồi
ảnh ở cái cốt của tôi và nãy bị lỗi
em ngồi bạn này Bảo sao ngày thôi thì nó
mới ra tiền được
ta có
đây ạ
em bận tí nha Đợi tí nhá
Hồ
Sơ X X ở đây
công
nghệ sĩ Lệ Thủy
ở đây à
đ.g.đ eva đi
cho thuê trả về đây là phát
xin lỗi đi d post gọi đến solid đi
à à
số 1 tại sao ra thành gọi cho em nhỉ
à À cái này là số
Ừ Rồi được rồi em theo không Nó số
Ừ cái bên này đó ạ chuỗi
Ừ nó chửi nhỉ
sơ mi lệ cach rửa này bắt buộc nó là
chuỗi ở số nghĩa đoạn này tôi
e-movie vừa nãy quy đổi nó ra số rồi nữa
ở trong d b là số mà tối nghĩa đoạn này
sẽ biến hết dành số ấy là được
Ừ Ok chưa
tiền nhỉ tiên bé tí
A Ngân trả tiền Dạo này là
à quên anh không nhắc quên đấy ờ
thì mình sẽ phải
à mình mình phải ở lưu lại tỷ giá trong
này Mình sẽ lưu lại là mình là người
Việt Nam đồng ý ạ Mình lưu lại thôi à
Việt Nam đồng Xong rồi Peru sẽ ra 23
nghìn nữa mà mình sẽ đưa lại là Ừ nó là
chú chó
khai
đã tiết kiệm nó lên
mình đưa trong này Tại sao bởi vì là
mình cái sao mình có thể cập nhật thường
xuyên con số này nhưng tôi từng nói mình
sẽ cập nhật có số anh thường xuyên thì
mình không nên lưu lại trong cốt những
cái lưu lại trong cốt ngày còn yêu mình
chả vừa sửa đấy thì mình mới lại trong
cốt thôi ai chia sẻ với kỳ đây đi anh sẽ
là Hello rồi mà ăn thì giá như một phẩy
1,6 thì phải ạ
thí sinh nhật
a good is to Euro II
anh alo 0.98
A2 3.300 rồi Đã thế
số tiền đó sao á
Anh nhắn nhầm rồi vãi chưởng à
a
tiếp theo
Ừ bye bye
giá này mày không hiểu
a tiếp theo là
vì
Korea luôn á
em gái
A11 nhìn cũng lớn lắm
A và đương nhiên để mình thoát nó ra
cách trở lại để bác nó ra mình sẽ
cái giá rai thì mình sẽ
sẽ có
e-blue này chẳng hạn thế
e-blue đặt tên đây rồi Sorry Sorry I
chị sẽ bằng nhà mình sẽ phải lấy à
anh ở đây mình có lô kết rồi à mình có
kia rồi ông ạ con khi đấy rồi mình sẽ
lấy á
ở Hà
cài đặt tên là ghét
anh ở đây sẽ truyền kỳ vào trong
ờ ờ
Ừ cái này không có tâm lý có ai sẽ là ở
là như này thi vào
A quack II Tại key này ạ sau đó thì mình
sẽ lấy Zalo nó này
từ đồng nghĩa lấy con chó luôn này
ạ
Và ở đây mình sẽ là
A One Piece
khi viết bài key rồi truyền thi vào
trong những ngày thì mình sẽ lấy được
cái à tỷ giá Ừ thì đây sẽ là
ở Sorry sẽ bằng tỷ giá thì mình đặt tên
là gì nhỉ được tên là
cho tỷ giá
từ nhỏ quên mấy cái này tỷ giá
áo vest ngoan cho tên reflect
bằng cái này lấy tỷ giá Đây đúng
Ừ nó sau đó Suri sẽ bằng cho zip
I mean
ở Sorry này
nhân với
a jealous để lấy tỷ giá
anh xóa chuyện sau đi và thẳng Nhưng ai
tương tự thế
cả hai sẽ mất đúng nghĩa sau
ở đó chuyện thằng ai vào đây
anh alo nghe truyền chào về kia thằng
anh nó báo lỗi em mình sẽ trả về là
em ra đây mình không có tâm trả về kiểu
gì nó chẳng giá trị gì đó có rất nhiều
giá trị mụn tâm trở về
I
betray ok
à à
thứ ngày
Anh Bình radio đây vẫn còn đúng không
chạy thử nhé
30 Tết Rồi
Ừ nó
nó vãi chưởng này À đúng rồi Vừa nãy
mình rồi
em chia cái con số này không chuẩn không
ạ thì ngày 10 triệu
chỉnh lại có số chuẩn đi
Anh
tên về 10 triệu
à không này
à Không này đúng rồi chia cho 23 555
[âm nhạc]
có bao nhiêu nhỉ
Em ngủ chưa
đã test này ạ
nhanh quá Mấy ông không bị choáng số này
ở đó là xuống anh
em yêu lại này
ở tại tràng
Ừ Ok chứ
ở đó xịn đúng ạ chị mà chị mà thử lại
nha thì đồng Euro chẳng hạn đúng không
cho đồng khác thì không mấy vào tô trứng
chó này kính
không chia này
về đến nhà lúc mà đăng bài mình sẽ phải
nhân chia thử dẻo tỷ giá nữa để mình lưu
lại trong thereby đó
Có ai có số 2 đúng ạ
mỗi này thôi nhá giả sử mỗi năm Nga Nhìn
tôi
ờ ờ
nó nhé
anh alo em
em nói sao nhận
mình vẫn đang chuyển Minh mắc lên thì
sao sử dụng mimax đi
nữa đâu em không ra được bài đăng đó đây
là đang báo lỗi không vào bài đăng
cơ thể thành nun
Có ai đi rồi anh em nhiều nhiều nhiều
nhiều lỗi tội lỗi thôi Ai đi đây lại đi
Đấy này
Ừ ok chưa
Ford 100 pro đồng loại sau đó hình như
mới được sự tăng ấy luôn ở lên ngọn Giả
sử là một con số vào đấy
này đi cho nó sẽ bị cá sấu đúng không ạ
ở đó
á nhon chứ
Ừ ok chưa đó Ờ
em đổi đây loạn hình bikini thôi
Ừ cái bài bài cây cái bài
ở bài ngày đăng Vĩ Dạ
Ừ anh hiểu rồi cái nhiều rồi
ở nhà mình không gọi rest is gì vậy
đã test rồi mày nghỉ cái bàn nhiều rồi
nhỉ
các kiểu thử đây rồi mai rồi
à à
ừ ừ
xuất cùng lúc nên mà mấy cái bài này
Thực ra là hai đi như thế này thôi Nhưng
mà như cái class thì nó khác thì phải
mình đã theo cột hết tất mà
ở ngoài giờ bọn nó bằng nhau thì nó sắp
xếp ngọn lắm Nếu mà mình nhớ mình chơi
theo kiểu là
chơi không phải lastest nữa mình sẽ
order bike
có một ID chẳng hạn thế Thì nó sẽ thị ra
cái kia
ở đó ngon chưa
vì thế nhờ giao diện nó xấu thì ông ngồi
trên giao diện tôi thì ông chơi cả ngày
nhưng mà cái xử lý bài toán nó sẽ ra như
thế này ok chưa đó Sao Bây giờ mình sẽ
Ware thì mấy cái này nữa loạn là được
đúng trước whey bây giờ hiển nhiên ở Sài
đường rồi quay Mình lưu lại trong tôi
bây giờ Lưu lại là USD mà nên mình chỉ
cần que cái xong đúng ạ
Ừ ok chưa toàn bộ buổi hôm nay đã sẽ như
này mình sẽ bao gồm Peter các từ thôi
nhé hai khi tơ ngon rồi khi tôi ngon rồi
nếu còn ý kiến đi
sẽ phải hôm nay tôi tổng kết lại nha hôm
nay đó là mình mình đã hiểu được cách
khi mình lưu lại trong bay vì lưu lại
như nào để dễ xử lý cho câu truy vấn
ngoại đấy cách mình lấy ra như nào hiển
thị ra như nào mình Mình lưu lại trong
con fix như nào để mình lấy ra vâng ạ
cách tôi xử lý nhớ ai đã thấy không code
này hoàn toàn là không nghĩ ít người chỉ
mày ông đến tận bước như này lắm đấy đấy
hoàn toàn mấy ông ngồi chia sẻ cốt ngày
mấy ông tham khảo nữa không ạ
Và bây giờ cách để một tổng kết hợp lý
nhất là tối nghĩa là bây giờ tôi sẽ ghi
lại có mít từng cái con nít thôi Chỉ có
mấy ông cách với con nít nữa đầu tiên là
tôi sẽ thưởng này Ờ tạo cái bảng có tắt
như này Anh phi trâu rồi update này
xong rồi Hoặc là à Thích này cái gì đó
xe tải tôi sẽ bạn nha
anh đi qua hết lại một lượt
khi chuyển sang hình dung ở mình đã làm
những cái gì trong bộ online
khi cài cái đầu tiên thì mình sẽ chỉ ăn
dặm là update update
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ
em không nhớ
tiếng Việt đi ừ
thì nó sẽ update lên này
Ừ nó
cũng được Tôi nghĩ tôi sẽ biết kiểu này
à
ờ ờ
Ừ Chắc chắn rồi nhìn cốt trong ổn thế
chắc chắn nó về sau tội lười tôi sẽ quay
lại bên này có cốt tiện
số kép
ừ ừ
Ê Cho xem tí nữa mai mai mình thêm cái
phi tơ Đông ạ Cái test này còn như bỏ
qua
you can pick này
chừng lên trước ngày mai tao xin ngay
Trần Thức ông chỉ cần nào trên thẳng lên
rồi tên của nó nó lên tất cả o ông sẽ
không cần con nít cái gì tạp cả ở
ông ông cũng chẳng cần phải ghi cụ thể
thêm cái gì cả
chị sẽ là
ở cây cái bên này là
Twitter này Peter Suri này đúng không
cập nhật Peter J ở đây này
ở đây này
là mình sẽ đẩy con fix lên trước bạn
chắc là mình sẽ lấy con thích là lên
trước
thì mình sẽ là
ờ ờ
biết đâu
chắc là cái này sẽ ra update
Ê họa Pixel tùy mấy ông đối tượng cái
này tôi nghĩa sẽ update hơn nó là
I get em cách
khi họ tiếp theo ở đây sẽ
ở nhà Peter
Sorry I
ấn vào đây sẽ ra ốp nikin bên apk game
PES phải cân cách viết nó sẽ ngay
ở
địa Sorry này đúng không Chắc cái thì đi
Asari
Ở đây toàn bộ sẽ là kiểu
ờ ờ update
à à
a z Safari I
A Gọi post lại
ở đó sẽ như này ra ông thì tách cái này
dưỡng da cũng được tùy nhưng mà nếu thế
Cái này phải đến trước Tại sao phải khái
niệm để đến trước đến sau vì Rõ ràng cái
này đến trước thì mình cái cốt đằng sau
lắm Nói chung là phải khai báo hạ phải
khai báo cái nào trước thì mới cái kia
nó mới chạy mà đúng không đấy
Ừ nếu như em mẹ không Thì ông đấy tất cả
cái cùng nhau ngay không nói gì cả nhưng
mà về sau nếu mà khái niệm Ông ông biết
khái niệm với voz không Cậu chọn đây sau
reverse cốt này đấy thì nó lên theo cả
một cụm của nó chứ không phải là từng
file hay ạ Hay bị nhiều quá không lên
nhà Nếu mà có mít từng cái nhỏ lẻ thì nó
biến nhất nhờ có mít nhỏ lẻ thì thì rõ
ràng là phải có mít cái nào nó được khai
báo trước rồi cómica nào xa và sau thì
nó sẽ như thế anh lại bỏ mày nó hơn 2
tiếng thì rất là già không ạ Nhưng mà
tôi thấy đến cuối buổi tôi vẫn nhiều
năng lượng Chúng tôi là bài hôm nay có
vẻ hay tôi cảm thấy hay không biết mấy
ông có thấy hay không nhưng tôi thấy
hạnh
anh đúng không Hôm nay học cũng tra cũng
được đúng không Mày thêm phải cái mới hi
vọng là béo không bị quá tải thôi từng
buổi từng buổi rồi Nghĩa dậy thế này à
anh cũng không khó lắm không khó lắm mà
nói nhiều đừng có nói như thật Âm Nhạc
Ừ thôi hôm nay chị thế thôi
Xin chào mẹ yêu nhé
lần thì
cần thấy thấy tôi cần sạc kỹ hơn ở đoạn
nào nữa Chẳng thế thì
inbox hỏi góp I sau nhé
Xin chào em